how's it going everyone everyone
everyone this is an all inclusive safe
channel where everyone can feel safe no
swearing no offensive humor nothing
triggering and I found the most peaceful
wonderful game ever said that everyone
everyone can enjoy this game I'm talking
of course about hand simulator see this
hand useless useless piece of garbage
hand garbage hand this get handed is
garbage
we're playing the real deal here ok we
can select shooting or spinners I'm
gonna go shooting play please wow wow
this feels this feels right this feels
just like the same oh wow look at this
you can't do that in real life you can
no no not stop what I say hand that's it
alright can I move my other one oh wow I
can touch my other hand with my other
hand I need help I can only control one
hand at a time ok alright so these are
the fingers it's almost like that other
game surgeon simulator but it's not
ripping it off at all look I am making a
bad no no no not that
that was close that was close ok ok now
slowly slowly slowly this feels just
like a reality how do I move it down
mouse wheel ok
yes okay let's grab that yes
so okay that didn't work
oh this is insanely hard I'm not sure
what I'm doing right now oh maybe I need
to charge it up oh my god
oh wait what is this oh wow
let me just a grab it how in the world
how am I supposed to reload a gun oh my
god I have to do it oh wow okay
alright fine my hand is a little broken
but that's okay which are my index
fingers use the thumb how you made an
input did I grab it now I don't even
know if I can grab it oh I think I got
it this is like pinching the world's
smallest nipple what the actual I'm here
how great I can't reach that far
great it's impossible oh oh oh oh
I got it I got it I got it okay okay now
somehow we're gonna put it in oh my God
we're so close
finger it finger it in how you know what
reset reset listen okay I think I'm the
only one in the whole world who played
this game on ironically you know what I
mean grab it like a real gun this is how
you grab a real gun right right I have
it I have it in my hand mm-hmm all right
you're gonna angle it down down we're
gonna know I flicked it back in again Oh
yeah that's not physics work okay get
that bun there hit the button hit the
goddamn button hit the got thank you
scrap the gun the gun alright yes which
hand again okay we've got the bullet
here let me do the spinners okay I'll do
the spinners thank you for oh wow look
at that look at that this is way better
oh my god yes I think I will go with
this one hmm
Wow look at that Wow look at that oh
this looks like a sharp one oh wow that
one's that one's there okay maybe we
should try this hand huh look at this
look at that one that one's spinning
look at that
that one's spun pretty good Hey look at
that yeah remember when steam used to
have standards yeah I want to die this
is where I want to die what is
multiplayer then huh Mexican stand up I
tweeted out for someone to join but I
guess no one else is that stupid no
one's this stupid huh oh my god someone
joined oh my god it's what okay okay
press the bunny press the button press
the button pressed
first of bunny someone actually bought
this stupid game press the button it
looks a bit weird when I have my arm
right no no no no no no no no stop oh
he's pressing button do you want to hold
hands hey hey oh my hand what is he
doing pointing at me no no no no no I
stopped stop down this game I have ever
played with anyone oh wow that looks
good that looks really good I always do
oh my gosh try to finger me oh wow
you're right there buddy why does my
hands feel so weird it's because you
never used them before again let's try
another one
gunfighter ok we're doing a standoff a
gunfight where's the gun though do the
whoopin Gangnam style
whoop no wait wait where do the kids do
the Naenae huh is that do the whip Onan
na I do their web web and doodlenet
peopie 2017 this is the most and
thrilling multiplayer experience I've
had in my life oh there there is someone
Wow someone joined hey hello oh there's
three of us
oh damn dude I like your pants okay okay
Kay Kay Kay Kay Kay all right cool
it started it started who's just gonna
live huh oh god he's got the gun he's
trapped the gun yes this is my chance
okay I got the gun I got the gun
alright alright I got the gun this is so
exciting
alright switch switch hand we just gotta
hit that button how you guys doing over
there he can't raise his gun yep and
flawless game I guess he can steal his
gun technically this game is ready for
you sports there it is okay now I just
got to grab one of the pole edge oh I
think I nailed it whoa look at that okay
okay okay okay okay okay
now somehow somehow get that bullet oh
my god I'm gonna be I there's a chance
No it's too hard
has anyone ever done it it's okay I got
three more chances I think I got it I'm
getting good at this I'm gonna see if I
can put this he's trying to take his gun
maybe this is a better angle yeah it is
okay no now I can't reach he's he
holding up I'm coming for you dude I'm
coming for you don't you worry I'm
clearly doing this with the wrong hand
this let's play melon simulator god
damnit early access game huh I'm sure
this one will be completed what what is
happening what is going on oh it's melon
[Music]
Wow video games have really come far
nice job team
thanks for leaving a like on this video
and I'll see you tomorrow with another
video probably not as good at this one
cuz this is gonna be hard to top I
really feel like squad fam out
[Music]